I saw an image of astronauts having a training session inside a spacecraft,...
...and it looked like so much fun.
I know that looks like fun,...
...but the astronaut training program is...
...preliminary to formal space transportation systems,...
...and is tougher than you could imagine.
It's not like you can just hop in a spaceship.
You need to do academic study which includes classes in shuttle systems,...
...in basic science and technology,...
...like mathematics, geology, astronomy,...
...physics and materials processing, and so on.
On top of that,...
...they also have to receive training in scuba diving,...
...space suits, and parachute jumping...
...as well as land and sea survival training.
Why do they need all those training sessions?
That doesn't sound relevant to me.
They need to learn how to deal with...
...emergencies associated with high and low atmospheric pressures...
...in the altitude chambers.
Nothing great is easy.
Let's say you passed all these training courses,..
...and ready for the space travel,...
...where would you want to go and what would you want to do in space?
Well, I would first visit Mars...
...where recent discovery says there's evidence that Mars had water on...
...or near its surface at some point in its past.
And it may sound unrealistic,...
...but I'd want to walk on the Moon!